what was the catalyst for starting this
program
so first off i'll just say my mother is
probably one of my biggest inspirations
um i grew up sort of watching her
navigate
entrepreneurship at a very young age she
migrated here from colombia um basically
you know right when she had me and she
kind of started her she's an esthetician
and she opened up a medi spa literally
by doing one chair and another salon at
a time and then grew it to three salons
at one point wow and then kind of like
the impetus of it all is like one day
with my husband we were trying to get
massages
and i
didn't love our options we didn't love
our options it was either it felt like
we were gonna have to splurge or we were
going to have to pay next to nothing and
i felt like i felt really guilty for
very different reasons
and i hated that i felt like there was
something missing right there in the
middle and i guess it all just sort of
snowballed i was like wow i think i need
to
kind of you know change up what the spy
industry looks like and modernize it and
make it more attainable accessible and
also inspiring where did the advocating
for mental health support come in
um so really kind of started with my
husband so growing up i didn't even the
word mental health wasn't thrown around
i'm an older millennial and i'm latina
so
the way we deal with mental health is
either yelling it out or like not
speaking about it at all and i feel like
we didn't have a health i didn't have a
healthy outlet growing up and i didn't
even talk about it i didn't know it was
a thing
and it wasn't until my husband really
came forward with um what he goes
through every day he's has an anxiety
disorder and it was just it was really
eye opening and i had to completely
immerse myself in what that may feel
like
and i still do um and so for chill house
i knew that you know even though we're
we do services in our spa and our
products are catered around bringing
that spa experience home
i didn't want it to just end at that you
know i wanted to be able to speak to
people that you know we fully understand
that not every
anxiety depression stress can be cured
with you know pretty nail art and
massages though i wish that were the
case
you know you really have to do the work
so our goal is really to be able to
partner with organizations that are
doing that heavy work
and support them however we can and
really want to continue to destigmatize
what mental health
is and make it more of a conversation
point not just have it be something that
we continue to bottle in every day
i love because there is such a tie
between wellness
and beauty and
the mental game and i love that your
husband inspired this and that you were
able to
fold it in and incorporate it and yeah i
think that it's just wonderful that
you're taking care of people on so many
different levels but trying to like venn
diagram it in the same
way with mental wellness absolutely now
um we're gonna do something today um
that's a flower art i happen to love the
word flower all things flower flower
beauty flower films i live right under
the banner flower um
so
i was excited about this will you teach
me how to do this yeah so it's really
simple i see you have a red nail bed
right there so i think a white would be
a great kind of contrast to the reds so
you want to use the little marble um
coaster there
to dip as much
polish as you can oh yeah so throw it on
there and that's kind of going to be
like your your home base for dipping oh
this is fine and dotting dipping and
dotting okay so just kind of you know
light little dot right here
or like put the little dotting tool
am i doing a petal or the center so
you're gonna go around so you're gonna
basically do a bunch of dots five to be
exact
around you're trying to connect the dots
and you don't want to press super hard
because that could maybe potentially
smudge the polish underneath okay so
keep it really light so and i'll follow
two
[Music]
three
four
and five
and see you see it just kind of leaves
like a little
thank you thank you worth of
encouragement so super cute and you
leave a little bit of space right in the
center there so that you get that little
center flower contrast you've got it
you've got it just connect the dots five
total oh and so this is such a cute
design that you can do like with your
daughters
i am loving this my second and third one
are not so bad it just oh my god you
killed it it's like so cute
my first one is uh
like the pancake
and uh always um that's a great analogy
my first pancake was a disaster okay we
heard from some of the women that you've
helped um thanks to your generosity and
um if it's okay can i share it with you
yeah okay wait take a look
cindy thank you for recognizing half the
story and for advocating for mental
health cindy's support of half the story
has allowed us to grow and help even
more youth thanks to sydney's support of
half the story we've been able to expand
our reach to youth all over the globe to
join our mission in destigmatizing
digital wellness sydney's support of sad
girls club helps us expand our
programming we've been able to offer
more sessions and touch more people all
around the world i know that your
support means the world to not just me
but everyone that's a part of the
sacroslav community thank you to cindy
for recognizing half the story and
advocating for mental health
and that's not all our team at flower
beauty was so inspired by you that they
want to make a 2 500 donation oh my god
um to the sad girls club
and
because i am
oh my god i'm so i'm so happy as well as
i am
uh half a flower beauty so i want to
match that and donate another 25 minutes
so
thank you use it to the way you see fit
and keep doing what you're doing thank
you so so so much just me so much i
always feel like i'm not not doing
enough for them and like this means the
world this is exactly why we partnered
with them so thank you very much thank
you so much
[Music]